наша підрозділи які знаходяться
підпорядкуванні тактичної групи
навантаження автомобіля для перевезення
майна плюс
сталінки
замовляли там мають матраси блешні
засоби все це скажу Так расходний
матеріал тому що БПЛА зрозуміло вони
кожен день втрачаються кожен день їх
збивають тут вони без питань потрібно
стерлінки
Понятно Це для швидкого управління
підрозділами дещо працює певний час
знаходяться під обстрілами і відповідно
виходить з ладу і так само вантажні
автомобілі для підвозок вони постійно
знаходяться під обстріли постійно
знаходяться в роботі виходять з ладу Ну
і це засоби які необхідні необхідно
тримати посівіговій готовності для
забезпечення бойових підрозділів
з 1999 року а під час війни
Чи відрізняється з першого Якщо говорити
про війну 14-го року і повномасштабну
війну звісно відрізняється тому що
і називають повномасштабна агресія
Російської Федерації тут застосовується
всі сили і засоби які є на
Збройних Силах Російської Федерації
починаючи від м'яса які він сюди
завозять періодично і закінчуючи
засобами якими вони
наносять удари по нашій території Чи
відрізняється армія що було до 14 років
до 14-го року це
були залишки армії хоча б багато хто
цього не помічав
[музика]
ну і зараз понятно дуже великий бойовий
опыт
мають офіцери солдати і цей опыт можуть
як мінімум не вважаючи озброєння і
техніку яка наразі є Ну це набагато ну
інші армії відрізняються дуже сильно за
цей час чи багато нагород ви отримали
Богдана
ви зустрічали 24 лютого у Пікселі
які були у вас емоції тоді в порівнянні
з емоціями зараз в Новий рік
[музика]
Які емоції можуть бути коли ввімкнув
телевізор зранку о 6 годині
одразу відкрив шафу дістав рюкзак зіграв
речі завантажив машини і поїхав на
службу
війна триває вже з 14-го року він
накриває 9 років тому тут Які емоції
можуть бути зрозуміло що це вже щось
нове до нового
людина ставиться по-різному кожу людина
в емоції Можуть бути різні Ну а це
просто
чергово так Скажем так етап які
відвіду до чогось ну невідомому на
новому місці в незрозуміло що буде але з
часом відповідно розумієш звикаєш бачиш
робиш висновки і відповідно не
налаштовують себе до роботи всіх умов
цих